milena no quiero usar baterías para
operar coches y helicópteros de juguete
todos los coches requieren el mismo
número de baterías al igual que todos
los helicópteros su meta es hacer
funcionar al menos 11 juguetes con
máximo 60 baterías eso es importante al
menos 11 juguetes con un máximo 60
baterías la gráfica de abajo representa
las restricciones en el número de coches
en y de helicópteros h de milena y en un
segundo vamos a bajar a ver esa gráfica
la desigualdad
representa el conjunto restringido por
el menor número de juguetes que milena
quiere hacer funcionar y bueno bajemos
un poco la pantalla para que veas a qué
me refiero si nos fijamos en la
desigualdad
bueno pues vas a ver que toda esta área
sombreada de azul incluyendo esta recta
de color azul así como todos sus puntos
son todos los escenarios en donde ella
hace funcionar al menos 11 juguetes
y después nos dice subamos la pantalla y
veamos que nos dice la desigualdad ven
la desigualdad ve representa el conjunto
restringido por el limitado número de
baterías que tiene milena ok
así que si bajamos a ver de nuevo esta
gráfica nos vamos a dar cuenta que la
desigualdad de es decir toda esta área
sombreada de verde incluyendo en la
recta y todos sus puntos son los
posibles escenarios en donde milena usa
como máximo 60 baterías y bueno veamos
que nos preguntan la pregunta es justo
hasta que tenemos aquí cuál es el máximo
número de helicópteros que milena puede
hacer funcionar cumpliendo ambas
restricciones bueno si nos fijamos en la
gráfica que tenemos acá abajo recuerda
que su meta es que quiere hacer
funcionar al menos 11 juguetes es decir
que estemos en el conjunto solución de
la desigualdad
o en la recta de azul y ella quiere
lograr su meta con máximo 60 baterías es
decir que también queremos estar en el
área sombreada de color verde de la
desigualdad ve con la recta de color
verde
en donde se sobreponen las dos áreas es
en donde ella cumple ambas restricciones
de hecho estaríamos en esta área de aquí
es decir en donde tenemos los dos
conjuntos solución bien ahora en esta
área marcada cuál es el máximo número de
helicópteros que milena puede hacer
funcionar
cuál es el máximo número de helicópteros
bueno si te das cuenta cada uno de los
puntos de esta gráfica corresponde a una
cantidad de helicópteros ya una cantidad
de coches y si queremos el máximo número
de helicópteros de esta área sombreada
bueno pues nos tenemos que fijar lo más
a la derecha que se pueda si nos
seguimos por aquí por aquí por aquí por
aquí vamos a llegar justo a este punto
de aquí en donde tenemos la máxima
cantidad de helicópteros y esto porque
recuerda que los puntos en las rectas
también están incluidos en nuestro
conjunto solución porque tenemos rectas
sólidas no rectas punteadas por ello
este punto de aquí que corresponde a
ocho helicópteros y tres coches cumple
perfectamente con nuestra meta
déjame escribirlo tengo ocho
helicópteros ocho helicópteros
o de los helicópteros y tengo tres
coches 3
sí sí
muy bien y justo por ello esta es la
cantidad mayor porque por ejemplo si tú
te fijas en algo que tenga más
helicópteros no sé se me ocurre nueve
helicópteros
bueno pues puedes observar lo siguiente
en nueve helicópteros no tenemos un área
sobre puesta es decir no cumpliríamos
ambas restricciones simultáneamente no
tenemos las dos áreas juntas entonces el
máximo número de helicópteros que
tenemos aquí son ocho helicópteros y ya
está hecho fue justo el punto en donde
se intersectan estas rectas que fue 8
helicópteros y tres coches y entonces
esta es la combinación que tiene el
máximo número de helicópteros en donde
milena cumple ambas restricciones y
cuáles serán esas ambas restricciones
bueno pues si subimos la pantalla
observaremos que su meta era hacer
funcionar al menos 11 juguetes con
máximo 60 baterías